un
deuxième vol habité réussi pour
l'entreprise blue origin à son bord
quatre passagers dont l'icône de la
science fiction le canadien william
shatner alias capitaine james t girls à
90 ans est la personne la plus âgée à
s'être rendus dans l'espace
il s'agit d'un vol très court 100 km
d'altitude dix minutes au total dont
quatre en apesanteur et un atterrissage
en douceur à la risée william shatner
était fébrile et heureux voiture
c'est ce qu'on appelle du tourisme
spatial entièrement automatisée que des
civils avec un minimum d'entraînement et
la promesse d'un voyage sans problème
mais à grands frais c'est toute la
problématique en fait du tourisme
spatial qui va créer en fait différentes
classes qui va permettre aux plus riches
aux plus d'aller dans l'espace les
futurs touristes ont maintenant le choix
à 500 km de la terre trois jours avec
spacex pour 200 millions de dollars à
100 km virgin galactic ou blue origin
pour une fraction du prix et en 2024 le
monde vu de ballons stratosphériques
pour presque une bouchée de pain
le tourisme spatial aussi un prix
environnemental élevé en septembre
dernier par exemple le long week-end de
quatre touristes de spacek autour de la
terre a coûté cher à la planète chacun
d'entre eux en volant dans l'espace a
généré autant de
d'impacts environnementaux que 85
traversée de l'atlantique en avion alors
ça c'était pour un seul vol
l'instant n'existe aucune réglementation
encadrant le tourisme spatial la
fréquence des vols commerciaux ni leur
impact sur l'atmosphère
se pencher là dessus dans un contexte où
ça va devenir de plus en plus commun un
peu à la manière où on réglemente de
trafic aérien est finalement l'espace
appartient à tout le monde pas juste aux
gens les plus riches c'est notre
patrimoine céleste et font prendre soin
[Musique]
ici non membres ondes radio canada
montréal